right let's bring in texas uh
congressman henry cuellar uh welcome
back congressman goes great to see you
good morning to you all uh congressman
this has been your issue forever you put
democrat or republican aside you just
try to secure the border for the people
that put you in office you have some
company this time that wants to keep
title 42 around from your party senator
hassan kirsten cinema senator kelly so
why is the president not listening
you know we don't know because look you
can't say we have a
pandemic or a public health issue here
but then say everything's fine at the uh
at the border and then lift the title 42
which is a health order you just can't
have both and we know like you all said
a few minutes ago 221 000 people this
last month and certainly right now the
cartels are looking at title 42 the
moment they lift that you're going to
stay seeing a lot more people coming
across
it's daunting uh it it's jarring really
and it's got to be even more frustrating
for you congressman as a member of the
democratic party to see politicians at
the very top who seem to
not want to address the problem and and
ultimately there's serious consequences
and you know it better than we do
including the fact that we're now
getting information that in 2021 there
were 23 known or suspected terrorists
caught at the u.s southern border in
2021 alone those are the ones we know
about in congress and the ones we can
actually do a background check on which
most you cannot and that does not
account for the people that were not
encountered by law enforcement so this
is a serious national security issue too
you know in the old days it was mexicans
coming in to come and look for work and
then they would go back to the country
with the monies that they made then you
started seeing about 12 14 years ago
central americans coming in right now
we're seeing people that are coming from
you know 50 60 countries all across the
world a lot of them have good intentions
but like you all mentioned some of them
are going to come in with bad intentions
and that's what worries me and and one
more thing if you talk to border patrol
this is very important in the laredo
border patrol only 40
of their men and women are actually
doing uh work at the border uh if you
look at the rio grande valley where most
of the people are coming in you'll have
50 to 60 percent of the people
that are are out there
out there doing processing work so think
about that 60 percent in both of those
sectors right now their men and women
are changing diapers or making food for
the migrants important work but they
don't belong there they should be out
there so we're only working with 40
of our personal border patrol don't you
know that the you know you can bet that
the bad guys know this yeah that's not
what the american people paid for they
didn't pay to have
border patrol who should be patrolling
her border changing diapers and
processing people instead of securing
the border and doing that law
enforcement work here's another case of
fraud waste and abuse if you ask me a
lot of americans just paid their taxes
yesterday and now we find out that the
dhs
blew 17 million dollars on unused hotel
rooms for migrants so i mean this is
just
another slap in the face of the american
people congressman
you know whenever they enter into those
uh contracts they have to do a better
job
uh in uh in negotiating because look
when you say hey you're gonna pay me for
this block of rooms whether they're used
or not used
you know we just have to do a better job
of negotiating now one of the excuses
that got given was well it was
unprecedented we didn't know this large
number of people coming across
yes we did yes we did so they just have
to do a better job in negotiating those
contracts well to your point guard it
was a sole source contract
and the government was obligated to pay
the 17 million for hotel rooms that were
not used why why are you signed
contracts like that i i don't have the
answer it's more of a hypothetical
question brian go ahead
congressman the main thing is we've had
policies that didn't work and ones that
did work this is a non-policy there is
no policy at the border
except for it to be to overwhelm the
border patrol and to diminish ice and
hurt their numbers and and their their
ability to do their job
i
what is behind this
i mean we don't even have a policy to
debate the mayorkissing company or m.i.a
and when they show up they get blistered
by the border patrol what's behind it
well you have to ask them for the right
they don't ask you
because they don't answer your calls
they don't come to visit you and ask
what's going on
well you know certainly i you know
sitting on as the vice chairman of the
appropriations
subcommittee you know we certainly have
put our uh what we've done is we try to
put as much money as we can
but they you know their motives you have
to ask them but i can tell you in
talking to the men and women in green
they don't want to have somebody from dc
come in and just give them a pat on the
back they want somebody to really have
their back and they don't and right now
when you talk to men and women in green
and in blue they feel demoralized they
don't feel that washington has her their
backs and we got to do more than just
give them a pat in the back
you know the the other 60 of the border
patrol the two sectors i mentioned they
want to be out there securing a border
they don't want to be changing the
diapers and and all that and we got to
understand and one more thing look it's
okay to listen to immigration
activists when when this policy has been
made but who's listening to the men and
women in green who's listening by the
border communities the mayors the judges
out there you gotta listen to the border
communities and to the men and women in
green yeah these ngos are making a lot
of money off of this situation as well i
think that's another part of this story
and and and the other part of it
congressman is your own party is
bleeding hispanic voters because of this
chaos at the border really appreciate
you joining us today you've always been
an honest broker um on this issue in
particular thank you for joining us this
morning
thank you so much okay hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now